Transcription: Maissane Nouari
Relecteur: eric vautier
Depuis toute petite, mon rêve,
c’est d’être une grande animatrice télé.
Il y a quelques années, j’ai fait un
entretien qui s’est très mal passé.
Complexe d’infériorité, style
vestimentaire non adapté,
manque de confiance en soi...
Mauvaise préparation, je dirais.
Au terme de cet entretien,
je n’ai même pas pu me retenir de verser
des larmes devant les recruteurs.
Mais avant de quitter la salle,
l’une d’entre elles me dit :
Si vous voulez faire
carrière dans le journalisme,
alors je vous conseille
de rester à la presse écrite
parce que vous ne pouvez pas
rester devant un public et parler,
encore moins devant des caméras
pour présenter une émission.
Vous n’avez aucune assurance. »
Mesdames et messieurs,
bonjour et bienvenue.
Est-ce qu’il vous est déjà arrivé
de rater une opportunité parce que
vous n’avez pas confiance en vous ?
Est-ce qu’il vous est déjà arrivé
de perdre tout espoir devant une situation
parce que vous n’avez pas
confiance en vous ?
Moi, oui.
Et vous savez,
la dame à l’entretien, en son temps,
je pense qu’elle avait
parfaitement raison.
C’était une période au cours de laquelle
je n’avais aucune identité
personnelle, professionnelle.
Et sa phrase,
je l’ai reçue comme une gifle.
Quand j’ai fermé la porte derrière moi
ce jour-là,
je me suis jurée de travailler
afin de développer la confiance en moi
et réveiller ce talent d’oratrice,
de communicatrice et
d’animatrice qui sommeillait en moi
et dont j’avais conscience.
Et aujourd’hui,
quand vous me voyez devant vous,
charmant public,
et devant ces caméras,
en train de vous parler
avec autant d’assurance
et de confiance en soi,
je suis sûre que vous vous demandez
comment j’ai fait.
Eh bien, laissez-moi vous dire
que dans ce déséquilibre,
moi, j’ai trouvé mon équilibre
grâce à la magie des réseaux sociaux.
Étonnant, peut-être, mais vrai.
Et c’est ce que j’ai envie
de partager avec vous ce matin.
Les réseaux sociaux m’ont bousculée et
m’ont permis de prendre confiance en moi.
En effet, après ce malheureux entretien,
Google était devenu mon meilleur ami.
J’ai lu des tas d’articles sur comment
développer la confiance en soi,
l’estime de soi, et grâce à ces articles,
j’ai d’abord fait un travail sur moi-même.
Ce travail consistait à définir
la personnalité que je souhaitais avoir.
Il fallait trouver un modèle, une ou des
personnes dont je pouvais m’inspirer
pour être la propre version de moi.
Et c’est ainsi que je me suis tournée
vers les réseaux sociaux,
qui se présentent aujourd’hui
comme la vitrine par excellence
pour suivre quelqu’un dans son parcours,
en apprendre sur son histoire,
son quotidien.
Sur YouTube et Facebook précisément,
j’ai commencé à suivre
des personnes fortes, intelligentes,
performantes dans leur domaine d’activité,
naturelles, et surtout qui assumaient
leurs défauts et leurs différences.
Je peux citer par exemple
Sonia Annick Agbantou, Frida Vibes,
Konnie Touré, Jessica Bamba,
A’salfo, Fabrice Sawegnon,
Gaëlle Prudencio.
J’ai lu des articles sur des sites comme
Irawo, Afriquefemme, Boussoleprécieuse...
J’ai suivi une formation
en prise de parole en public,
et laissez-moi vous dire
que c’est encore
grâce à la magie des réseaux sociaux
que j’ai entendu parler
de cette formation.
Il y a quelques années encore,
moi, j’étais très complexée par mon corps.
Mais aujourd’hui, j’arrive à m’assumer,
et donc à m’accepter parce que je voyais
sur Internet des gens comme moi.
Là, c’était avant.
Et vous allez voir maintenant,
avec beaucoup plus
de confiance et d’assurance.
J’ai appris à rêver,
parce que grâce aux réseaux sociaux,
j’ai découvert un monde de possibilités.
J’ai appris à m’assumer, parce que sur
Internet, il y avait des gens comme moi.
Mais contrairement à moi,
ils étaient très fiers d’eux,
et j’ai décidé d’en faire autant.
Et je suis sûre que c’est le cas
de beaucoup d’entre vous ici.
Vous convenez avec moi,
mesdames et messieurs,
qu’une personne qui porte un handicap,
mais qui s’affiche fièrement
sur les réseaux sociaux,
peut donner confiance
à une autre personne dans le même cas
et qui n’ose pas s’afficher.
Vous convenez avec moi qu’une personne
qui expose fièrement ses vergetures,
ou son vitiligo sur Internet,
peut redonner confiance
à une autre personne
qui se bat jour et nuit
contre ses imperfections.
Une personne qui a aujourd’hui
une réussite,
qui est une figure de proue
dans son domaine,
alors qu’elle a commencé
au bas de l’échelle,
peut redonner confiance et motiver un
jeune qui veut entreprendre aujourd’hui.
Oui ! Moi, j’ose le clamer haut et fort :
les réseaux sociaux peuvent changer
positivement nos vies.
Au-delà de ce qu’ils peuvent nous apporter
sur le plan de la confiance en soi,
ils nous permettent également de nous
découvrir, d’identifier nos talents,
et de les mettre en avant.
Je veux citer par exemple Grand P,
DJ Couclick du Bénin,
DJ TikTok de la Côte d’Ivoire,
Khaby Lame, le TikTokeur
avec plus de 118 millions d’abonnés,
Luca Loutenbach,
le supporter devenu célèbre
après être passé par toutes les émotions
lors du match France-Suisse
du 8e de finale de l’Euro 2020,
ou encore Kabulo Junior,
l’enfant prodige du Net
qui commentait dans des vidéos des matchs
en imitant le journaliste sportif
congolais Claude François Kabulo.
Je pense à cette jeunesse africaine
qui a pu sortir des griffes du chômage
grâce aux réseaux sociaux.
Que dire encore de toutes ces personnes
qui lancent des SOS chaque jour,
et qui arrivent à trouver une solution
grâce aux réseaux sociaux ?
Mesdames et messieurs, grâce aux réseaux
sociaux, moi, j’ai une vision plus claire,
et plus large du monde, de la vie.
J'ai réussi à prendre conscience
de mon plein potentiel.
Je connais mes forces
et je connais mes faiblesses.
Grâce aux réseaux sociaux, j’arrive
à m’informer, à développer ma créativité,
à faire des connaissances
et même des expériences professionnelles.
Aujourd’hui, je fais mes premiers pas
dans un métier qui me passionne -
l’animation radio, télé et live.
Chers invités, je ne vous apprends rien
si je vous dis que,
pendant la crise du coronavirus,
les réseaux sociaux ont été
d’une grande importance pour nous,
ils nous ont d’abord permis
de rester en contact
avec les personnes qui nous sont chères,
et nous ont permis de nous informer
sur l’évolution de la pandémie.
Ils nous ont surtout permis
de garder nos jobs,
parce qu’on pouvait travailler
par télétravail.
Qu’aurions-nous fait sans ces outils ?
Cependant, l’utilisation des réseaux
sociaux est un couteau à double tranchant.
Eh oui, parce que sur les réseaux sociaux,
mesdames et messieurs,
il y a également le harcèlement,
l’intimidation, la cybercriminalité,
le cyber-harcèlement.
Il y a aussi la dépression, les mauvais
commentaires, les fake news,
et surtout la dépendance.
En janvier 2020, un film est sorti :
« The Social Media Dilemma ».
C’est un film très instructif
qui parle du côté négatif
et de la dépendance
vis-à-vis des réseaux sociaux.
Déjà, soyons clairs :
la dépendance vis-à-vis
des réseaux sociaux est une réalité,
et elle devient même inquiétante
au fil des années.
Mais tout dépend de ce que nous faisons
quand nous passons
la majeure partie de notre temps
sur les réseaux sociaux.
En réalité, ce ne sont pas les réseaux
sociaux qui sont dangereux ;
c’est l’utilisation que nous en faisons.
Je suis sûre que dans la salle
il y a des personnes qui manquent
de confiance en elles.
Je dis ça, mais est-ce qu’il y a des
personnes qui, comme moi,
se retrouvent dans la même situation,
il y a quelques années ?
On va faire un exercice.
Fermez les yeux s’il vous plaît.
Et posez-vous intérieurement
une question : qui suis-je aujourd’hui ?
Et quelle personnalité j’ai envie
d’avoir d’ici un, deux, trois ans ?
Ouvrez les yeux, merci.
Il y a sur les réseaux sociaux
des personnes qui peuvent vous inspirer,
et vous aider à devenir
la meilleure version de vous.
Vous n’avez pas besoin de la connaître
personnellement, mais ils sont là.
Ils postent chaque jour
des contenus inspirants, motivants.
Ils parlent de leur histoire.
Je ne vous demande pas de copier ces
personnes parce que, comme j'aime le dire,
moi je m’inspire des autres pour être moi,
et c’est ce que je vous demande de faire.
J’ai vu récemment dans une vidéo
Samuel Eto’o qui disait :
« Dieu m’a béni d’un talent,
celui de savoir jouer au foot.
Mais j'avais besoin d'une lumière,
celle venue de Roger Milla.
Il m’a permis de rêver, et le rêve est
le commencement de toute réussite. »
Mesdames et messieurs,
parfois, nous avons un talent,
une aptitude, dont nous ne nous
rendons même pas compte.
Et c’est quand nous voyons quelqu’un faire
quelque chose à côté qu’on se dit :
« Ah mais tiens, je peux le faire aussi. »
Beaucoup de créateurs de contenu
aujourd’hui
se sont inspirés d’autres personnes.
Retenez qu’il n’y a pas d’originaux
comme vous,
mais il y a des personnes
qui vous ont précédé,
et qui peuvent vous montrer la voie.
Certes, on dit aujourd’hui que
les gens ne montrent
sur les réseaux sociaux
que ce qu’ils ont envie de montrer.
C’est vrai !
Sur les réseaux sociaux,
il y a peut-être des personnes fausses,
mais il y a également
des personnes authentiques, vraies.
Ce sont des personnes
qui peuvent par exemple
poster une photo d’elles sans maquillage,
alors que vous avez l’habitude de les
voir avec du maquillage tout le temps.
Ce sont des personnes qui peuvent
poster des photos d’elles
en train de manger au village
dans une casserole bien noire,
alors qu’elles ont l’habitude
de vous montrer des photos
dans lesquelles
elles sont dans des restaurants.
Ce sont des personnes qui partagent
d’anciennes publications
pour vous montrer d’où ils sont partis.
Ce sont des personnes
qui vous racontent leurs échecs.
Aujourd’hui, mesdames et messieurs, toutes
les personnes qui me connaissaient avant
s’étonnent encore du changement
qu’ils observent à mon niveau :
de la fille complexée, sans aucune
assurance et vulnérable,
je suis passée à la fille qui s’assume,
qui s’accepte et qui s’aime.
Nous sommes tous des êtres singuliers.
Nos expériences ne sont
peut-être pas les mêmes.
Notre histoire n’est
peut-être pas identique,
mais il peut y avoir une similitude
entre ce que nous vivons chaque jour.
Et c’est en cela que je dis :
se baser sur les expériences des autres
pour se construire,
ou, si vous voulez, se reconstruire,
peut être important.
Mesdames et messieurs, aujourd’hui, moi,
j’arrive à rester zen
face aux challenges de la vie.
Je ne vous dirai pas que je suis forte,
que je n'ai plus peur.
Non.
Les moments de peur, de doute
et d’incertitude s’installent encore.
Mais, quand je vais sur Internet,
et que je vois des personnes qui
traversent des situations difficiles,
les scandales et tout ce qui va avec ;
quand je vais sur Internet et je vois des
personnes qui ont traversé ces périodes-là
et qui aujourd’hui gardent
encore le sourire ;
quand je vais sur Internet et je vois des
gens qui sourient à la vie à chaque fois,
je me dis : « S’ils peuvent le faire,
pourquoi pas moi ? »
Et si moi je peux le faire,
pourquoi pas vous ?
Je vous remercie.
(Applaudissements)